[Music]
It's God. It's God. It's God the
Israel
[Music]
basically is a primary reason to be a
Muslim. Okay. Because the Quran. Okay.
So can you show me something which is
make you Muslim strong Muslim something?
I know you're saying that because of the
Quran. Give me one particular reason
>> why I'm Muslim.
>> Why I'm Muslim? Yes. Which is make you
more stronger Muslim. Well, I think my
faith is quite beautiful. Um miracles in
the in the religion, you know, it makes
like a stronger faith and just in
general like I don't know. I'm not sure
how to really explain it, but the wisdom
behind the Quran.
you going to give me any
>> for for example the prophet Muhammad
said that it's better to sit down and
drink water and that's because it's
better for for your digestion but that's
been proven recently there's many things
like um but
>> but this is this is the Quran what
you're saying
>> no that was a hadith I also
>> so you are so you basically saying that
if Muhammad say that you have to be
drinking a water when you sit down and
it's a medical I mean reason to be okay
what is the reason medical reason. So
water goes to your to the leg or
something.
>> No, it's better for digestion. I'm not
sure the exact science behind it cuz I
said I'm not really scient
that's what you believe. I have no
problem. Maybe if you talk to Hindu they
say
if you talk to Hindu they're going to
say that's why Hinduism is the best
religion. Right.
>> Yeah. For example, Christians are going
to say that Christian is like
>> yeah that's not I mean we have to have a
reality or the fact in there so you
going to be think that this is the
better version or updated
religion how you going to say that give
me a one reason
>> you're saying that Jesus is the son of
god
>> yeah the Quran saying that son of
>> he's a messenger of he not
>> yeah and there's also like for example
you guys are talking about
contradictions in the Quran but there's
also many contradictions in the Bible.
Not only not only like like I don't know
how to explain it but like
contradictions itself in the Bible but
then also in the logic of the Bible for
example that Jesus is the son of God but
he is God but then if he is God then
he's not all knowing he's not all
knowing like God is supposed to be if he
is God he died like
>> the problem is only you guys watching
and zak you guys don't leave the Quran
that's where the problem is you know
whatever you're coming with the
questions that's all zak Good night and
shman is okay. So where where you going
to find out what you're saying in the
Quran?
>> What do you mean?
>> So what you saying that science or
anything whatever you saying where is in
the Quran and you saying the
contradiction in the do you know any
contradiction in the Bible? Uh yeah,
which one is
>> for example I'm not sure the verses but
um there's two bits one says Judas he
got uh I'm not sure exactly but he got
silver coins and
that's it. So that's why that's why I
say when she shikhman going to stand in
front of us he's going to run because he
he does not know exactly he's talking to
the people who doesn't know that much
bible okay and but we are after she hman
being last 3 years he doesn't want to
come to the park so better to talk about
yourself which you know from the Quran
forget about the shman zak like they are
lying to you they are lying to you
basically because see we after him and
he doesn't want to talk to us
>> okay one thing it's written Muhammad's
equal
Yeah, we will we will we will go for
that. Let's go to uh in the Quran. So
Jesus is the son of God according to
Isaiah is the son of God. Can we show
you that and then we go from there?
>> Unless everyone mention something. No
I'm pretty sure that's common knowledge
that
>> Can I show you that?
>> According to Quran Jesus the son of God.
>> No it doesn't say that.
>> Yeah. Can I show you?
>> All right. You want us to go something
or you want to go?
>> I was going to show him uh cuz he asked
for a contradiction. I was going to show
him that.
You want to show the contradiction
first?
>> Uh yeah, sure.
>> You want to show the contradiction
first, then I'll show you.
>> No, as I said, I'm not I'm not ashake.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I I'm not I don't want you
to like give an answer. I just want to
just show you what I mean. So, um I'm
going to just show you two verses that
the Quran is like pretty consistent on
this.
>> So, you have um if we go to surah Anam
chapter 6 uh where am I at? Oh, 14.
Okay, we need to go back. We go to
chapter 6
and we go to verse uh 14.
Uh it says, "Say, shall I seek for judge
other than Allah, when he it is who sent
unto you the book explained in detail?
They know full well to whom we have
given the book that it is sent from you
from your Lord in truth." Right? Never
be of those who doubt. So the we're
going to focus on he circled it. It's
funny. But explained in detail. The
Quran is explained in detail, right? So,
and now I'm going to show you. Oh, you
want to sit there? Uh-huh. Okay. So, the
the Quran is a book that's explained in
detail. Um, there's another verse that
says this, and it says just a little
little bit more detail there. This in
chapter 12, Sir Ysef, uh, verse 11.
Okay.
Sah 12.
All right.
So surah 1211 it says there is in their
stories instruction for men endued with
understanding. It is not a tale invented
talking about the Quran. It's not
fabrication but a confirmation of what
went before it. A detailed exposition of
all things and a guide and a mercy to
any who believe. So the Quran it's a
confirmation. It's not a fabrication.
It's a detailed exposition of
everything. Right? Everything that
that's in the book. So it's pretty clear
the Quran is supposed to be perfectly
explained in detail.
>> So now the contradiction comes
>> necessarily because the and the Quran go
hand in hand.
>> That's the point. So there's like for
example there's things in the Quran that
it mentions but not in detail. You got
to go to the hadith to get it right.
You'll get the rest of those details.
That's a that's a problem.
>> It's written in the Quran to pray in the
>> It tells you how exactly. But he's
saying in the Quran it says that the
Quran is detailed. So yeah, could you
could you go back to the verse where it
says that the Quran is detailed?
>> Yeah. Yeah. This this Yeah, this one
says it. It says it's a detailed
exposition of all things, right? So it's
it doesn't just explain some things, but
it explains all things. So it should
tell you how to pray, but it doesn't.
>> But God cannot come down on earth and
teach us how to pray. We need someone
like us, like human teach how what to do
and what not to do. I I would say that
cuz you know similar to how how he was
able to use I guess Muhammad and others
to show you how to pray in the hadith. I
believe that you know Allah could have
put that in the Quran right he could
have lit put a section here maybe a
surah on how to pray and what steps
>> in schools you have books but you need a
teacher
>> to teach you.
>> Yeah you need a teacher right?
>> Yeah.
>> So that's not a teacher. No, no, cuz the
Quran it's detailed with all things in
the sense that it tells you to follow
the hadith. The hadith is mentioned in
the Quran as in like not quite sure how
to explain it but it's a part of the
Quran. It goes hand in hand.
>> I so I agree that the this is what I
agree with. I agree that the hadith and
the Quran go together. I do agree with
that but I don't think the I wouldn't
say that that the Quran points to the
Hadith. It does. The hadith backs it up
for sure.
>> Yeah. is the Quran says to follow the
teachings of the prophet Muhammad. the
prophet the teachings that the teachings
being the
>> right so now so here's the issue okay
cuz cuz I agree with you it does say
that that Muhammad you know you follow
his teachings right obey Allah obey the
messenger and stuff like that right the
problem is is that the Quran claims like
it has this claim the statement that it
explains everything but it doesn't if it
if it if it said it explains some things
let's say necessary for your guidance or
necessary for your wisdom then I then
you know I wouldn't have an argument but
it doesn't say it says it explains all
>> things teachings of prophet Muhammad
there's also an explanation
>> yeah but it's that that's outside the
Quran
>> but the thing is cuz since it tells you
to follow the teachings of the prophet
Muhammad that explanation from from the
hadith it's like
>> you don't have to explain it but
>> the teachings in the hadith are is is
him expounding on what's in the Quran
>> is that right
>> yes so so so
when You're learning from Muhammad.
You're receiving the statements of
Muhammad that are not necessarily in the
Quran. He's giving you more details,
maybe a deeper look, your code,
a deeper look on, you know, on on um you
know what the Quran is saying. See, now
look, trust me, everything you're saying
makes sense. Everything you're saying
makes sense. Every book is going to have
some ambiguity to it. Not every book is
going to have everything mentioned,
right? I am reasonable enough to
understand that. My issue is
>> is that exactly
>> I feel like this is a very
iffy contradiction to pick out. It's
like oh it says it gives you detail but
it doesn't give you detail. So the time
is wrong. But so my my thing is is that
because because Allah says if this isn't
from Allah then you can find in it
contradictions right this this is even
if it was even if this is small like
even if it's like oh it doesn't really
shake the faith
>> it is a contradiction like and Allah
who's perfect can't make any even if
it's small any contradictions you know
>> I don't think it's a contradiction I'm
not explaining myself really well I
can't really like
>> No he's saying that it says it explains
everything in detail but you're saying
there's parts missing like instructions
Yeah. You want my sweater, bro?
>> You sure?
>> Missing. But it also says follow the
prophet Muhammad's teachings and those
missing instructions are in his
teachings. So it completes in the like
the pro when we believe in prophets and
Quran and all the angels and everything.
Okay.
>> So whatever is written in Quran,
prophet Muhammad.
>> So let me let me let me give you an
example guys. So what if cuz what if
there's something in the Quran like for
example Muhammad doesn't expound on
everything there's some things he
touches on there's some things he
doesn't right like so for example the
crucifixion of or the crucifixion of
Jesus right how Allah made it appear
yeah it's in the Quran now Muhammad
nowhere in the hadith he he never
touches them right so then now if we
look about uh look at like that event I
can ask like okay what happened you know
what like let's just look at it really
quick and let me show you Why? It's like
it's super ambi ambiguous, you know.
>> Yeah, the story. Yeah, like it it
doesn't say what is going on here. Um,
exactly. So, we go 157. Um, okay. Here
it is. So, so, uh, that they said, so
talking about the Jews boasting, right?
Um, we killed the Christ, Jesus, son of
Mary, the messenger of Allah. But they
killed him not nor crucified him. Um,
but it was made to appear so unto them.
And those who differ therein are full of
doubts with no knowledge. Uh but they
only follow conjecture. For sure they
killed him not. Now my question is this
right? When it says uh Allah's
responding to them when they say we
killed the Messiah and he says they
neither killed them nor crucify him,
right? But it was made to appear. So
what does that mean? What happened? You
know there's a lot of different theories
but but what happened
>> in the big picture? All
right. He's replaced by somebody. That
is a that's a theory. But
>> that's more of like a weaker hadith that
people in the like in South Asian they
believe, you know, that he was replaced
by Judas or whatever similar. It's not
necessarily in a hadith, but a lot of
people do believe that. It's more of a
misconception.
>> So there's not really anything backing
up.
>> You know, you're absolutely right.
>> But my comment on this is that in the
bigger picture, it doesn't really have
to matter. It's not really a
contradiction if it's not mentioned in
the Quran because the Quran was given as
a guidance to us. And since the Quran is
already saying that Jesus was not
crucified, I personally don't think it's
necessary like for the Quran to
elaborate on exactly what happened in
detail.
>> What the what this is referring to I
it's not saying that like oh they think
they killed him but it wasn't actually
him done. It's more like it's more that
we believe he was just raised to heaven.
He didn't die.
>> He didn't die.
>> I hear you. But but
>> I think so. But but do you guys see how
ambiguous this is? We there's different
theories. There's a Judas theory.
There's a even there's a young man
theory.
>> But so so I I I don't think that this is
straightforward when it's like if I if
I'm coming I'm reading the Quran, right?
Uh outside looking in I'm like this is
interesting and I want to know what
happened. The Quran doesn't tell me what
happened. It just it's very vague. You
know what I'm saying?
>> But you said earlier that every book
would have some ambiguity.
>> So I don't see why it's a problem.
>> The problem is is that the Quran claims
there's no ambiguity. That's the only
problem. If the Quran never said, if the
Quran never said that there's ambit that
there's it's fully detailed and
explained, I would not have an issue.
But the fact that it makes the claim
that it explains everything in the book,
I have a problem when it doesn't. You
know, that's the issue.
>> Can I say something?
>> Sure.
>> How many Christians are following Bible
nowadays? No one. Because it's written,
no wine. Okay. Cover yourself. Nobody's
following. But it is not in the Bible.
very strong. It is in the Bible.
>> No, it's it's it's in the Bible that
that you can't get drunk, right?
>> No, no, no. You can't you can't get
drunk. You can drink, but you have to be
responsible with it. You can't you can't
get drunk. You don't have to wear a
hijab, but you do have you should you
should No, that's not in the Bible.
>> If I'm not mistaken, in the Bible, it
says that it's a shame unto a woman if
she doesn't veil her head.
>> All right. So, like that's during
prayer. So, during prayer, yeah, during
prayer, she has to have a covering of
her head, but it also says that um that
her hair is her covering. So like if a
woman shaved her head then that would be
shameful like you know. So
>> I see this
>> I I see that.
>> Yeah. You can see
>> Yeah. I see I say that you guys have a
strong faith. I do believe that you guys
love God and have a faith in God. You
know what I'm saying? I'm just I believe
that and and I say this out of love.
Like I respect you guys. You guys are
beautiful people. As a Christian from
what I believe I do believe that the
it's it's a little bit misguided in the
wrong way. You know, I would really want
to want to show you guys Jesus.
>> We are misguided. Our
>> I don't want you to be misguided though.
>> Yeah, but our our faith is strong. But
in Christian, in Hinduism, in Judaism, I
don't find anybody like following their
religion.
>> Well, well, yeah, of course you're going
to find people that, you know, you're
going to find bad apples in every
religion, you know.
>> No, no, no. You're going to find bad
apples in every in every religion. But
what what matters is what does the
source say? Is the source of it the
truth? You know, they're like, "Don't
look at me. Don't look at me. Don't look
at how I act or whatever." I would point
you to Jesus and what how does the Bible
how does Jesus teach you how to be? You
know, if I'm not following Jesus, don't
look at me. That doesn't mean that Jesus
is wrong, right? So, you know, I would
want you to look at what Jesus taught
and he taught that he came down. He's
the son of God came in the flesh to give
himself for our sins. If you guys have
questions on that, I would love to
answer that. But, you know, this is it's
really it's life or death. It's heaven
or hell, you know, right? Obviously, the
Quran says if anybody says that Jesus is
the son of God, then Allah's curses upon
them, they're deluded from the truth.
Jesus says in the angil in the gospel,
whoever does not believe that he's the
son of God who came in the flesh, then
they're going to be condemned. You know,
so this I both can't be true, right? So
we need to get to the bottom of it.
>> So of the contradiction you were saying
that the Quran says that explains
everything fully but then it's showing
some ambiguity in the full story of how
Jesus was not.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
Let's say there's also many other
stories. For example, the when when the
world flooded with prophet Noah,
>> there's not it doesn't give a full fully
detailed story about exactly what
happened to to the dog.
>> You're right. So I don't think it's
really fair to just pick out one
situation and
>> I I I will that was just one example
brother. I can and you gave me another
one. I can go through the Quran bro and
give you multiple examples like for
example um
>> because I I feel like since I'm not
knowledgeable to the like to the extent
I my opinion is that someone who is can
can answer your question.
>> Brother I've I've I've spoken to very
knowledgeable Muslims like people who
call themselves shakes, imams. I've gone
to the Majid and brought this question
to them and um what what they what some
of them have told me is I either I'm a
deviant in my heart for asking this
question or um I need to ask Allah for
guidance. That's what they've told me.
But there's they haven't been able to
give me a logical resolution to how to
reconcile this, you know. And it's not
that like as you see I'm not being
unreasonable. I'm very reasonable. I'm a
very logical person. I'm very
reasonable. If there's a reasonable
explanation, I would take it. But there
isn't. I looked at the taps. I looked at
the scholars of Islam. I've looked at,
you know, Ibikir and the court. I've
looked at all these guys and how they
broke it down. They there's no
reconciliation. Now, they won't say that
there's a problem. I see the problem,
you know. So,
>> wait. So, what was the verse?
>> The verse of the thing. Sometimes in
some English Qurans, they it's it's a
different meaning. I mean, like, you
know what I mean? Like, different
wording.
>> For sure.
>> Check. Mhm.
Do you uh speak Arabic too or No,
>> I don't speak Arabic.
>> Okay.
>> So, it's chapter 12 verse 111.
>> So remember that like this is the reason
why this matters is because Allah says
if you find contradictions in this book
then it's not from Allah. That's what he
says. It's that it's a challenge to the
disbelievers like he challenges us find
something find something wrong with it
you know so 12
>> yeah 1 yeah 12 verse 111
>> all right it says a detailed explanation
of all things
>> so now you you can argue that him saying
that Jesus was not crucified and it was
only made
It's not detailed to the dot. You know,
this person was replaced by this person.
It made it seem like that. Whatever,
whatever, whatever.
>> But you, you could say, you know, I
guess, okay, I can say that there is a
detail that here, here's the detail that
Allah made it appear.
>> That's a detail, but it doesn't give us
all details.
You know, like I said, if it if it
didn't say a detailed explanation of all
things, then I don't have an argument.
>> You get what I'm saying?
>> I don't have an argument.
>> Like, as I said, I'm not knowledgeable,
so I can't really answer the question.
>> Brother, you you you are knowledgeable.
You you you say you're not, but you are.
And you you've shown it in this
conversation cuz you're thinking. You're
thinking and a lot of people don't have
that uh what do I want to say that
attitude to really critically think
about a problem being brought even when
you it goes against your belief. So
you're humble and that's beautiful. So
stay like that. Never change.
>> Me personally I don't think it's a big
thing that's going to shake my faith cuz
I do believe that there's an explanation
behind it. It's just that I don't know
how to explain.
>> What if you don't what if you don't find
one?
>> What if you found that there was no
explanation to that? Then would that be
a problem?
>> But do we need an explanation?
>> You do. Because cuz if there isn't, then
this isn't from Allah.
>> No, we just know that he hasn't died and
he's going to return.
>> No, cuz regardless regardless if I don't
get an explanation, I have an
explanation in the back of my mind. I
just really can't explain it. And I' I'm
trying to like get the words out. I just
can't.
>> Okay.
>> If you show me a clear contradiction,
for example,
>> this isn't clear.
>> This thing happened here and then this
thing happened here. For example, in the
Bible, how the way that Judas died,
that's a clear contradiction.
>> No, it's not. Let me let me I I'll break
that down. Yeah. Let me
>> I' I've seen the question being asked by
Fatiman many times, but I've never heard
like an answer about it.
>> Yeah. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. So, so for
example, so you got Judas. It says that
Judas died by hanging, right? He hung
himself.
>> And then there's another verse that
talks about how um Judas fell headlong
and his his guts burst out, right? So,
we put two and two together. It's not
either or. It's both and. He hung
himself and after dying and being and
being dead from his hanging fell and um
and and his guts burst out. His body was
decomposed by the time that he
>> How do you fall from like from this and
then
>> No, brother.
>> Wait. Yes. Exactly.
>> Just to head long is head first, right?
>> Not all the time. No. So that that's one
definition. Also headong just means
suddenly just means quickly. So the like
let me show you um the the
>> telling that is falling by.
>> Yeah.
>> I'm asking how do you go from vertically
upright?
>> Yeah. It's it's not it's it's not it's
not head first. It means look look
here's the definition. So um so one of
the definitions is head first like
you're saying. Another definition is
without deliberation meaning recklessly
right without pause or delay. Okay.
>> You know so following headong. And there
was also that he donated the silver
coins to the
>> he threw it at them. He threw it to them
like he th he he he threw it at their
feet like I don't want this. So he took
the he he got the money that that he uh
you know betrayed Jesus with went into
the temple and threw them I don't want
this anymore.
>> So that was as a donation.
>> I wouldn't say donation. It was
>> just to confirm the verse said that he
donates it to the priests.
>> No he threw he threw it he threw it in
the temple
>> because there was one that he threw it
on the fields or threw at the field. So
there so it says so the chief priest
bought the the field with the Judas's
money.
>> So right he so so that's why it can say
like for example that Judas bought the
field because his money was used to buy
the field
>> right but he he didn't
>> if he's throwing it at the priest and
the priest buy the field with that money
how is it really Judas buying that
>> cuz it's still his money cuz they so
they used his money to buy the field
>> right? So, for example, if you dropped
some money on the floor and I used that
money to go buy something, is that you
buying that thing?
>> You can in a sense. So, either even like
for example, um let's say like for my
birthday, he gave me like $3,000, right?
>> And I use that $3,000 to go buy a car. I
can say Anthony bought bought me this
car, you know? Even though he didn't go
to with bought you that car, he didn't
buy the car.
>> Yeah. Well, notice what I'm saying. Even
though I went to the dealership without
him and I used the money to buy the car,
he didn't come with me. He didn't, you
know, but he gave me the money to buy
it. You know,
>> he bought you the car, but he himself
did not buy the car.
>> But, you know, exactly. In a so in a
sense.
>> Oh, okay.
>> You get it? Yeah. Okay. Yeah.
>> Yeah. So, same same with the field.
>> All right. That makes sense.
>> And then what about um for example, many
people say for example, he says that in
the in the Bible Jesus never claims to
be God. Oh,
>> he he for example he says I and the
father are one. You guys use that as a
verse, right?
>> Yeah, for sure.
>> But then he also says that I and the
disciples are one.
>> Yeah. So so these are two different
contexts. So you have the this when he's
talking about the disciples, he's
talking about sending them out into the
world. And he's praying for their unity,
praying for them to be of one mind,
right? One movement, right? And so he's
praying, he's like, "May they be one as
we are one and them be one in us and
yada yada." Is that is that an inter
interpretation or is that as like a
context?
>> That's that's the context. Yeah. The
context from the previous verses and the
later verses. Now with that as well when
it comes to Jesus saying I and the
father and one a few verses before that
he's saying he's saying some crazy
stuff. He's saying the sheep they're my
sheep. He's and they know me and they
follow me. He says I give them eternal
life and no one can snatch them out of
my hand. And then he says the father
who's given them to me is greater than
all. No one can snatch them out of his
hand. I and the father are one. So he's
saying that he and the father are one in
giving eternal life.
>> Right? So only God could give eternal
life. So Jesus is talking about a
oneness of substance like he's one in
nature with the father not just unity
and purpose like he is with the
disciples.
>> So would you use the same explanation
like basically the trinity to explain
why Jesus does not know the hour the
father does?
>> No. So it it'll be different like um if
you talk about Jesus knowing the hour uh
it's kind of deep but let me show you
for example um
>> so like I would use this context
>> just real quick cuz I got to go.
>> Okay that's going to take longer.
>> Yeah it it'll be a longer
>> I'm going to show you the other
contradiction you saying that. Okay. And
I'm going to show the voice say that uh
Issa is the son of God. Okay. It
>> says that the son of God.
>> Yes. In the
>> son of God.
>> Yes.
>> In the Quran.
>> In the Quran. Okay. Okay. Let me show
you that one before you leave. So
>> the same
you guys are reading the same because
listening people that's a problem.
>> I've read the Quran multiple times in
English.
>> Okay. Let's go to that.
>> I'm sure there's some context behind it.
>> Even if it does say that there's no if
you can read this one here.
How do you say that?
>> If you read that
>> Yeah. From our spirit as as Abra sorry
Gabriel Angel Gabriel.
>> Okay.
>> It's our spirit was angel Gabriel. He
came down and he brea into telling you
guys where Gabriel here.
>> No, it it shows in other it shows in
other English translations.
>> The first
angel is here.
>> I I'll show you in
another translation.
Whenever the spirit is referred to like
>> no bad spirits are under two different
>> they're not even
>> that's what they're teaching they're
telling you that's what they're telling
you but that's not true
>> no because God Allah does not refer to
himself as a spirit in the body
>> no look at look at here he's saying that
here Rohina and that
>> yeah spirit okay it's not the what's the
angel you know
>> yeah Okay. But it's here the saying
means spirit of Allah. He bring e to
Mariam and the baby. That's right.
>> Okay. That's what I'm going to do. So
I'm Allah. Okay. And I came to Mariam
and I put the spirit in Mariam.
>> But you're not doing that. You you sent
down angel Gabriel to do that.
>> Why did you send down here? That that's
why they're telling you that's why
you're reading a wrong translation.
>> I'm I'm aware that
>> Okay. No. If you say that I'm in the
wrong translation, I could say the same
thing that you're that you're in the
wrong translation. You can't really make
>> I can I can put any
I can put out any translation you want.
I have
>> Okay, I'm putting out this translation
angel Gabriel.
>> Okay, let's go to
>> I remember the one who guarded her chase
to see it. So, we breathe into her
through our angel Gabriel.
>> Look at through our angel Gabriel.
>> Oh, they're lying.
>> Yeah. See, where's the where's the Look,
look at the Arabic. Where's the angel
Gabriel? No, I mean,
>> you know, for example, for example, you
know, when they refer to father in the
Bible,
>> let me let me ask you say father or god
in brackets every single time
>> in the bible when they say like our
father, they're referring to
>> Jesus or whatever.
>> Yeah. Father, the spirit and the holy
there's different father and we don't do
the practice. But this is all
but anyway let's go to back here. He
said that
>> no but the thing is
soul spirit spirit is referred to as
angel Gabriel. No refer does not refer
to God in any
not saying that he said that he said
that we said we uh okay and her who God
just we okay we who are we here
>> we is is God Allah
>> God okay so God he put the spirit to the
>> okay
>> from our spirit
>> yeah so our spirit that mean our spirit
>> as from our from our angel
So yeah, see I know that's why you are
reciting. Okay, you keep reciting
whatever you recited, but
>> no, but I'm reading the same words that
you're reading, but I'm seeing it in the
context of the rest of the Quran where
we're told that spirit refers to angels.
>> No. Okay, but I'm going to show you
that. We're going to come back to it.
Okay. Here, if you're saying the spirit
and angel, they are two different.
>> What's what's the what's what's the
floor where it's we're talking about
angel?
>> What are you looking for? No, I'm just
uh No, no, I got it here. There was just
stupid.
Okay. What you saying that?
>> Um just like
>> just thinking about this.
>> I need talking about angel.
>> Okay. Look at here. If you can read this
one, so that can help you out.
>> The day that the spirit or the angels,
the day that the spirit.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So, so they're they're two
different stuff. They're not same. What
you try to say? No, because it says
spirit and then it says
>> that's why it says angel spirit and the
angel will be standing. So
>> So his his point is is that there's a
distinction between the spirit and the
angels. That's his point.
>> So they're not saying
>> so if if because Gabriel is an angel,
he's not the
>> you could say Gabriel and the angels.
For example, I could say
>> you could say and the people
>> Gabriel and angels are same. We don't
have no problem with that. Gabriel and
angel.
>> Yeah, understand that. When you're
saying that you're saying why is there
>> special angels? So they're
>> Yeah. So no cuz you're saying why is
there a distinction between spirit and
the angels?
>> No. No.
>> The one.
>> No. No. So his his point I hope
hopefully you guys get it. His point is
is that there's a distinction between
the angels and the spirit. Yeah.
>> If Gabriel is an angel then he's not the
spirit. Those are two different classes.
>> That's his point.
>> That's the that's the question. And
>> but spirit refers to him specific.
>> Yeah. Because because for example, God
Allah sent down the spirit to give the
revelation to Prophet Muhammad, the
angel Gabriel.
>> So So okay, so to be real, there's not
there's no verse that says that Gabriel
is the spirit. There's no verse that
says that.
>> However,
>> it doesn't say that, oh, Gabriel is
>> here. However, here's here's how the
logic goes. The logic goes that Gabriel
brought down the Quran. He brought down
the revelation, right? There's another
verse that says the kudus, the Holy
Spirit, brought down the Quran, right?
And so people two put two and two
together and they say okay that's that's
Gabriel must be the Holy Spirit. However
the problem comes when like obviously it
doesn't say that but you can make that
connection but then you have verses that
distinguish between the angels and the
spirit
>> for example the spirit.
>> Yeah exactly. So so when we and there's
multiple like that. So the spirit is
always distinct from the angels. And
then also there's a verse that says that
this the angels come with the rule uh of
of Allah's command with the spirit of
his command to bring the warning to who
he will. So they're both bringing down
the revelation.
>> Yeah. But then I could make the argument
that prophet Muhammad is the same as the
other prophets, you know, Noah, Moses,
whatever. So I could say that Prophet
Muhammad and the prophets, sorry, I
could say Muhammad and the prophets.
Yeah. If I'm understanding you correctly
what you're trying to say, you could
basic you could say that Muhammad and
the prophets, then you can't really make
the argument that they're
>> Yeah. But so you you would have a good
argument because the Quran says Muhammad
is a prophet. Matter of fact, calls him
the last, right? The seal of the
prophets. So you have a verse that
identifies Muhammad as a prophet. So you
can then elsewhere say Muhammad and the
other prophets or Muhammad and the
prophets.
>> Here in the Quran, it doesn't say
Gabriel is the spirit. So that's the key
part that's missing, you know,
>> right? But then you have, as you said,
you have the two verses that says, "Oh,
the the Holy Spirit came down to recite
the revelations of Prophet Muhammad."
And then, "Oh, Gabriel came down to
recite the revelation to the prophet."
>> So, it's what what what's stopping us
from saying both of them did it, that
both the Holy Spirit and Gabriel brought
down the revelation together,
>> but we know it was just Angel Gabriel.
>> No, what's what's telling what's telling
you that wasn't the case? That it was
two different people.
>> Okay, sure. So, for example, if we go to
uh 16 16
>> are you trying to argue that there was
maybe two different people?
>> I'm I'm saying that there's two agents
or two entities that have brought down
the revelation.
>> Well, that's so like for example in
chapter 17 when they Allah says when
they ask you about the the spirit uh say
that you know that knowledge is only
with Allah. He's only giving you a
little bit of information, right? So, we
don't know who and what exactly the
spirit is.
Um but uh if we go to chapter 16
uh so in in chapter 16 verse two if I
can get there
chapter 16 verse two
hopefully this will translate correctly.
Yeah. So it's a little I'm not used to
this.
>> Okay. Here it is.
So you see how so so this is interesting
how it translates it but the word is
spirit. So it says he does send down his
angels with now this says inspiration of
his command
>> to such of his servants as he uh as he
pleases um with warning right that there
is no god but I so do your duty unto me.
Now in the Arabic it's R that it's the
angels are sent the angels come down
with the R. Uh if you can
>> is it from here?
>> Yeah.
>> With the spirit of his.
>> Yes. Exactly.
>> Is this the verse?
>> Verse two.
>> Wait. So you're interpreting as a
physical spirit.
>> No, not physical but as a it's a it's
another entity.
>> Right. Right. Other than the angels.
>> It refers to angels as R.
>> No. No. It says angels with the ro.
Sometimes it's angels with the role of
his command
>> with inspiration. Here he's saying
inspiration is rule.
>> So inspiration or spirit of his command.
It's like spirit of I thought
>> I it doesn't mean physical spirit. If
it's saying spirit of the command, it
could it just means like the spirit of
something as in like
in high school.
>> I think Yeah. Like the spirit of school.
I I get what you're saying. I I get what
you're saying. So
>> the essence of his
angels, right?
>> Yes. Okay. Yeah. So, so this this is
this is my argument. Now, I understand
what you're saying. Here's my argument
is that
>> is that according to the verse, right?
There's a there's a distinction between
the
Malika Malika
>> Malika and the RO, right? And of his
command.
And you have the other verse that says
that the Rrook of Kudus, the Holy Spirit
brought down the revelation. We see that
the angels come with the Rook and they
bring the revelation together.
>> So I can argue that the Holy Spirit with
Gabriel the angel together brought down
the Quran, the warning.
>> Right. But then before you were saying
that God is the spirit.
>> Wait, is that what you said?
>> That was not no. Okay. Sorry. Sorry.
>> Okay. Because I was going back to the
one where you were saying that that
Jesus is the son of God in the
>> Oh, that's Yeah, that that's his
argument. So,
>> wait. So, you're saying that Wait, so
your your point was being that uh angel
Gabriel is the Holy Spirit?
>> My my point is that they're different.
That the angel Gabriel and the spirit
are is Yeah, they're two different
entities.
>> So, so you're saying Gabriel is not the
Holy Spirit.
>> Correct. I I don't I don't have any uh
there's because there's nothing that
identifies him as it and because there's
verses that distinguish the angels from
the spirit and that they also come
together bringing revelation then uh you
know I'm like okay I don't I don't have
any evidence to say that he is the holy
spirit that he's the same thing
>> but like it's like for example surah
it's constantly mentioned that angel
talked about
>> that's true
>> but there's There's no other like name
mentioned. And then if you're saying the
spirit came down with the message of the
god, you you can put two answers
together.
>> Yeah.
>> It doesn't need to be mentioned for it
to mar.
>> The the reason like like I said, I'm
reasonable. I hear everything you're
saying and I I I see what you're saying
up to a point. Like if the Quran didn't
do this like continuously show a
distinction between angels and the
spirit,
then I I you would have a point. or even
showing that the angels come with the
spirit bringing revelation together.
>> Sorry, could you repeat
>> that the saying the wording is
confusing?
>> I I don't think it's necessarily
confusing. I think it kind of it rules
out this uh or
>> I don't think it's black and I don't
think it's black and white that it's as
clear as day that an that Gabriel is the
spirit
>> in some cases. You're right. In some
cases, however, when it comes to like
for example, uh the Holy Spirit, like we
know that the Holy Spirit in the Bible
is the very spirit of God. He's he's not
an angel, right? He's not a creation,
but he's the very spirit of God, the
essence, sharing the essence of God, you
know, who comes and gives revelation and
guidance and strengthens the prophets
and believers. That's who the Holy
Spirit is very clearly in the Bible.
>> So, but if you can argue your point, we
can do you agree that it's ambiguous
enough for us to argue our point. And
then if you put that together with the
fact that God constantly punishes those
that associate him with others or kindly
take away from his like all his just
like singular power
>> seeing that he
like prophet Issa is his son would kind
of take away from his power because he's
able to have a son.
>> I I wouldn't I wouldn't say it would
take away from his power and let me tell
you why. Like so we we believe that God
is the most loving right we agree with
that that he's the most loving right
he's he has the greatest form of love
greater than our love right so for
example because God is the greatest he's
the he's whatever we can conceive he's
the he's the greatest when it comes to
love that means he's the greatest right
so let me ask you this what is a greater
form of love just loving yourself which
is good you got to love yourself right
or or loving sharing your love with
another. Which one would be greater? The
shared love, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Would you agree?
>> Okay. So, this means that God within
himself would have to have at at the
very least the attribute of shared love,
right? Meaning that that requires
another person.
>> He has it from his creations already. He
doesn't need someone related to him.
Like, would you say like a dad and a
son? using a son is um
>> yeah having a son is not necessary for
him to love other people. Now, now
watch. Let me show you guys the problem
with that. Cuz that's the that's the
obvious like, you know, thing. Like he
he loves his creation, right? He loves
his creation. But now notice this. For
God to have this idea. For God to have a
greater form of love,
>> he is relying on creation to have that
shared love with.
>> So that would mean he's dependent on
creation.
>> Asking his forgiveness. He says, "You do
this. Just apologize to me. Come back to
me and I'll forgive you. That's how much
I love you." Understand
>> the worst thing to ask for doesn't
change.
>> Understand?
>> God being the most forgiving is also
>> yeah I I would say but yeah I I agree
that his forgiveness is like a subset of
his love. My problem the problem is this
is that for God to have shared love that
higher quality of love he needs create
he would need like in y'all's idea he
needs creation to have that shared love
with. So without creation there is no
shared love within God. He needs
creation to have that higher that
greater form of love.
>> Are we not the creation?
>> Yeah. We're the creation and basically
so look God for God to be God means that
he's independent, right? He doesn't
>> that's what we're saying.
>> Yeah. But but with this idea of love,
this means that God is dependent on
creation to have shared love.
But with our with our concept of of God
because God is multi-personal because
there's the father and the son and then
the spirit
>> that shared love is within the essence
of God even without creation.
>> So is that is that the logic you use for
God having a son?
>> The Yes. Yes. That's it.
>> Yep. Because because God is love at his
core. He is love. He's the most loving.
That means that God will eternally and
infinitely generate another person to
have a higher quality of love with
because in his essence he is love. So
>> Okay. So your argument is saying that
God having a son does not take away from
his power.
>> Exactly. I I would say that it actually
shows his power. Okay.
>> Shows power without having to have all
of it.
>> Exactly.
>> Yeah. I understand. But at the same time
like saying that he directly created
someone a son that's like you're saying
he's above us right?
>> Mhm.
>> Then does that not also say that God
there's an essence of God in Jesus in
prophet Isa we believe we're just a
regular human being.
>> I know abilities.
>> Yeah.
>> We believe in like giving life and
whatever.
>> So so pay attention to this cuz this is
man we're getting we're getting in some
good places. This is getting good. So if
you want a burger too, I'll buy you a
burger too. Um uh so this is the you're
absolutely right that if within the
essence of God, God the father generates
the son, this would necessarily mean
Yeah, exactly. This means that he has
the same essence as God. Now,
>> but that's what's constantly not allowed
in the Quran.
>> I know. And and here's the thing. So
then you put the context together and
it's like okay he must be saying spirit
as in just breathe life into having
Jesus without conception.
>> But there's a difference because the
Quran I'm telling you you're right that
the Quran is you know has pretty clear
statements that Allah is one by himself.
He doesn't have a son all this kind of
stuff. Right.
>> You don't need like super clear
sentences because there's a lot of stuff
you need context.
>> I agree. I agree. These these these
things are pretty clear. Now, here's
another I guess caveat. She's like,
"What?" Now, so you know how the the
Quran calls Jesus Allah's word, right?
The word of Allah.
>> That's all the prophets.
>> No, no, no, no, no, no.
>> It's specifically Jesus.
>> Only Jesus is is Allah's word. Only him.
>> He's because I mean
>> the prophet Muhammad brought the word of
God.
>> Prophet Ma brought the word of God.
>> Yeah. But they're not called the word of
God themselves. They brought the word
>> different things.
>> Correct. But they're not the word.
>> But in in the way it's the same thing.
>> It's nowhere near. Let me tell you why.
So there's a difference obviously from
bringing God's word, you know, and
sharing and being the word of God
itself.
>> But in a way, the prophet Muhammad was
the word of God in itself through his
actions.
>> No. Yeah.
>> No. The Quran doesn't say that. It
doesn't say that. Yeah. Sure. But I'm
saying
>> so this is bidd
innovation. No, it's like interpretation
though cuz for example like the prophet
Muhammad was the word of God through his
actions like in the hadith there's
hadith where you know you whatever you
see from his actions. So he's being the
the word of God in that sense.
>> He's anam he's an example of the word of
God, right? Of how the Quran or the
message.
>> But he calls him the word. He's my word.
He says
>> about Jesus.
>> Yes. About Jesus. Yes. Yes. About Jesus.
He's identified as God's word.
>> I think we're just going on linguistics
because also he calls Prophet Abraham
his friend.
>> Yep.
>> Which is true.
>> He's my friend. That doesn't mean
Prophet Abraham's another God.
>> I agree. Yeah. being being a being a
friend doesn't put you doesn't give you
the nature of God. No, it just means
that you know there's a caring
relationship there, right?
>> For example, how but the word Moses
could talk to God. It didn't mean that
he went to that he went to
>> Yeah. God God Yeah. God communicated
with him very clearly differently than
he did anyone else. Right.
>> And it doesn't make him better than
other prophets.
>> I would agree. I would agree that none
of those things, friend of God, being
the one that God spoke to directly
doesn't necessarily make you different.
But what makes you different is if
you're being identified as one of God's
attributes,
>> his word that like for example got his
like revelation,
>> revelation, his decree, his order, his
command like like for example, the Quran
says that whenever Allah decrees a
thing, he says to it be and it is right.
That's his word making something happen.
It's so the Quran identifies Jesus as
Allah's word. So if it's through Allah's
word that he creates everything and
Jesus is Allah's word, then that would
mean that Jesus is the one who he
creates everything through that he
orders everything by that he decrees
everything by. That puts Jesus above
everyone.
>> You could you No, I understand what
you're saying. You know the verse where
it says
>> he's the word.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh chapter 4 verse um 171.
>> No, but I'm saying even if it does say
that, you could interpret it as that.
But us context of the rest of the Quran
and seeing how like there's a huge focus
on just the oneness of God. You're only
worshiping God. You don't even worship
the prophets. We don't worship them or
put them above like
>> on a pedestal kind of
but
>> you don't worship right. Um,
so using that context,
you can also just understand the fact
that
>> so this look cuz I I'm not I'm not going
to say this. Let me just give you guys
my standpoint.
>> Of course. Yeah. Yeah. The Quran
>> 447 you said
>> 471.
>> 171.
>> Yeah. So yeah, you're saying that the
Quran is clear contextually about the
oneness of Allah. Don't worship anything
else. And I agree with you. Um my
position is that
even with that th this is where the
inconsistencies come. I don't believe
that the Quran is perfectly consistent
on these things because yes in places
like it says Allah is one he doesn't
begin nor is begotten, right? Um it has
no associates and no partners, no
companions. But then
>> more consistent with that.
>> Yeah. I I would say that that's more
>> Yeah. I would say that that's the more
prevalent message than this one that we
see with Jesus like where him being the
word of Allah and a spirit from him
>> just mentioned once
>> twice mentioned twice but but yeah
compared to the two different one
chapter 3 and chapter four
>> compared to everything else
>> yeah but compared to everything else
it's very little right however it's huge
though it's huge you know that that
changes the the whole trajectory of your
theology
>> if it was that huge it would have been
mentioned more though like we wouldn't
have such a focus on prophet Muhammad
then we should have prophet
>> I agree that why why do why do you think
that he that Muhammad's not that big in
the Quran he's not
>> it was revealed to him this is talking
to prophet Muhammad
>> okay
>> when he says like uh when he says like
okay so these people are saying you
should say this back to them he says
this a lot right
>> you say it's or not you just say
>> but say Yeah. Cool.
>> Because this is
>> they're getting really they can hate it.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. So over here it says that the
Messiah Jesus son of Mary was no more
than a messenger of Allah and the and
the fulfillment fulfillment of his word.
>> Yeah. And and that's false. It doesn't
say that he's no more than a messenger
and it doesn't say that he's the
fulfillment of his word.
>> But you said that it says that he is the
word of God.
>> Yeah. So look if you cuz you you know
the Arabic, right? You can read the
Arabic. So what does it says?
All right. So notice Yeah. You see it?
Yeah. So notice and notice how it didn't
say that he's no more than the
messenger. It says say right.
>> Yeah. Exactly. So the English
translation is is messing with that
stuff.
>> We're going to get in trouble. We have
to
>> Guys, I deeply enjoyed this
conversation, man. It was it was a
pleasure to meet you.
>> Your actual, you know, studying the
Quran because a lot of people just bring
up arguments for
>> Yeah. Yeah. Of course, guys. Some
preachers, they're just like, "Oh, and
this and that, whatever."
>> Yeah. No, I I I have a huge love for
everyone. So,
>> yeah. It was so nice to meet you guys,
man.
>> I'd love to uh stay a bit more and talk
about this.
>> Yeah. Do you do you have an Instagram or
anything, man?
>> Uh yeah, I do.
>> Yeah. Let's get each other's Instagram,
man. Let's stay in touch, bro.
>> So, this this is God Logic.
>> Oh. Oh. Oh, yeah. You already know.
Yeah. Okay. So, yeah. Let's Let's stay
in touch cuz like I don't want this to
be the end. Like, it's it's very weird
that
>> my last name. So,
>> yeah. Okay. Yeah. All right. No worries.
Um, but I'm coming back in a couple in a
couple weeks, so we'll see you soon.
>> Yeah. Hit me Hit me up on Instagram,
bro. All right. It was a It was a
pleasure.
>> Good night, everybody. Bye. Bye, sister.
Bye.
>> Logic.
[Music]